hi there i'm back from montreal and i
had a fabulous time um montreal is a
great city it's full of life especially
in the summer i guess in the winter it's
a little
colder and this event the polyglot
festival or the language festival was
full of so many
people interested in languages
very supportive of each other just a you
know basking in in a glow of of
friendliness and
i had a fabulous fabulous time very glad
i went and i will definitely go to the
one hopefully it'll be in montreal again
next year north american polyglot
symposium and it's not just for
hyper polyglots although there were a
lot of people there from i don't know
age 15 to 70 who spoke four five six
languages
but even if you are interested in
learning one language i really recommend
you go we're going to post a link to my
talk
uh
the video it's a bit long you may not
want to listen through all of it
uh and i basically talked about what i
call it can you can do you need to speak
to be a polyglot
and i stress the importance of
of allowing people to define how they
want to engage with the language those
who want to speak those who want to
listen and read maybe delay speaking
but i did make the point that in order
to achieve
a significant level which i would
consider b2 on the european framework
scale
it you need rich input that rich input
leads to rich output and i showed some
of the examples of the resources that
are there to make this possible and
i was thinking about you know what makes
link unique because there are many
systems for language learning and i'm
sort of been struggling to find a simple
explanation of what's unique about link
and we had a discussion in our office
and i asked our three link academy
members what their opinions were and i
also gave my view so you can have a look
at this video that my granddaughter
annie filmed where we discuss
what k what makes
uh link unique what is what makes
link different from other language
learning systems so uh please have a
look
and
the theme that we discussed and i'm not
going to tell you what the conclusion
was or what we came up with but it's
something that i think is going to be
part of of link as we explain link
going forward and the other thing i
should mention quickly is you know
however good link is for those who
understand it is not very good for those
who don't understand it and therefore
the
process of developing this new version
of link which we call the beta
we're coming to a point where we can put
something up for everyone to use and i
can tell you that i'm very excited about
it and but again it'll be up to you all
of you to try it out and see so the
question is what's unique
to link i was asked
and i have my ideas on it should i give
my ideas first or should we get others
but you go ahead first
i mean i haven't
seen
this kind of structure before it gives
you the
basic principles how like a
baby would learn a language from from a
breeding block to building block
uh but it you support with links
to somehow gather all the information
together usually other
i don't know ab or website gave us
some kind of subject or paragraph or
words anything that we have to learn but
if i'm not interested in that subject or
something then
it's really easy to just give up in
different language usually we learn from
what what's over grammar and then we
connect each other and
then starts reading but in link we
started from learning from reading
articles so we
feel the language first and then go back
to
understand the beginning
part you know and it relates to what you
were saying
it relates to what you were saying and
to me the the difference between
for example there was a guy there called
benny well benny the irish polyglot he's
come up with a new series of starter
books but you're quite good i think
they're quite good i was i told them i
said they're i think they're good
they're pleasing attractive
and um and there are lots of starter
books out there there's lots of systems
out there that what distinguishes link
is
that with link there's no limit
like
we actually go to fluency
you know
it is possible to take link just link
and go as far as you want all the way to
fluency you can't do that with if you
buy a book from teach yourself or some
other system rosetta stone it doesn't
take you all the way to fluency
link takes you all the way to fluency
those other systems
they don't even take you close they get
you started
so basically there are lots of people
doing that first spurt
get you you know to get you started most
people never get past that
most people stop either early
maybe most people never ever open the
book when they bought it you know maybe
i don't know but but most of them stop
and even if they do the book
you know and of course the book always
says complete korean you know if you do
this little book now you will be just
you'll have mastered korean which is
completely wrong
you are barely a beginner at the end of
that book you are barely a beginner
and
fluency to me is if we look at the
european scale there's six levels it's
like
the fourth level it's b2 it's a high
intermediate
when you are a high intermediate you can
call yourself fluent and then you can
continue to develop as much as you want
so i think if someone asked me to like i
didn't
tetsu organizer he asked me so what's
what's unique about lincoln i really
didn't have an answer
then i thought about it and it's the
fact that we go all the way to fluency
and in fact i think most people who are
doing link properly want to get to
fluency
they don't want just to say hello how
are you look at me i can speak spanish
those are not the people who are going
to stay with link the people who are
going to stay with link are the ones
that actually want to get the fluency
and with link because because we use
uh you know authentic interesting
material because we encourage people to
learn from the language itself all of
those to learn therefore how children
learn their first language by hearing it
and by reading it and because we have
you know you can bring in whatever you
want to learn from bring in things of
interest you can just keep going forever
so i that to me i just thought maybe
that should be our slogan you know all
the way to fluency
i was thinking that i should i'm
thinking i and i've sketched it out now
i should write a book
all the way to fluency
how do you get all the way to fluency
and maybe we do all the way to fluency
in french all the way to fluency in
spanish and so forth
but to me that's that's what link is all
the way to fluency and you hear the sort
of artificial dialogues in those books
where everybody speaks very clearly and
and so that's all you can do when you
get out in the real life in the real
world people don't speak like that but
you're right too about pushing people to
get out of the sort of beginner
artificial language content so i was
just thinking again of my crossfit where
they push you when you come you're first
you're in the sort of base
base camp then you go to this next level
and the next level and maybe we should
have more
sort of events that push people
to maybe we should have more like weekly
who has the highest activity index and
who has graduated from the beginner
level content into authentic content
more of that stuff where people are
encouraging each other pushing each
other because at some level everybody
would like to be fluent
but then it's
i i didn't quite understand it all i
have to listen to this lesson again and
this is too difficult and maybe we
should have some kind of activities that
get people to push themselves
further because the goal
i think for anyone who comes to link
should be fluency
that's what people should be striving
for